la feria de nîmes se termine ce soir
tous les aficionados ont pu assister cet
après midi à une corrida équestre
mais nîmes n'est pas la seule à fêter
les taureaux et les vaches toute la
camargue s'en mêle comme à cassagnes de
reviennent nicolas à vins clairs et
jean-louis melun ça avait commencé
plutôt pas mal la journée tout le monde
s'était donné rendez vous pour un p'tit
déj sauf qu'il n'y avait pas de corn
flakes ni de théo nuage donné une
sangria pour la route et des saucisses
pour démarrer les chevaux les hommes et
les taureaux partent vers l'arène
ici le but du jeu quand on a 15 ans et
de mettre de l'imprévu dans une
tradition qui est comme les saucisses
trop bien huilée derrière il ya des
centaines de kilo de corne de fureur et
de muscles vous êtes d'accord pour avoir
peur alors on s'échauffe la fête peut
commencer
la course camarguaise rien à voir avec
les corridas qui se joue là où à nîmes
ici pas de sang sur le sable pas de mise
à mort du taureau entre les cornes de
l'animal on fixe une cocarde
elle est mise aux enchères le but du jeu
c'est l'attrapé un sport réservé à des
initiés
car avec 300 kg qui vous cause
d'arriérés paie sa mamma mia
on évite estropiés bonjour et quand on
veut on atterrit à des risques ben oui
aux enfants là cela facile mais bon faut
pas les empêcher
il est 22h encore de la sangria encore
des saucisses en fait on n'arrête pas de
petit déjeuner pour les enfants du
village la même peur avec un modèle
réduit
on a sorti la vache est bon mais j'ai
pas peur non je suis ta au début un peu
l'impression mais après une entame un
ring si sous terre où ça remue toujours
le coeur de faire la fête on attend
l'animal la gorge serrée mais le sourire
aux lèvres à trois ans déjà
la reine est un bac à sable l'on s'amuse
de ses peurs
ça y est ça devient sérieux il est une
heure dans les rues de caissargues les
taureaux sont lâchés
leurs corps n'ont été gagnée mais quand
le taureau a peur c'est simple il charge
à leur corne ou pas cornes c'est comme
en amour
mieux vaut se protéger qu'est-ce qui la
soirée comme celle là quand on a vécu
c'est c'est l'ambiance
la fête s'est terminée vers 3 heures il
n'y a pas eu de blessés pour fêter ça
allez hop un verre c'est l'heure du
petit déjeuner